les éleveurs français tout comme les
agriculteurs veulent donc faire entendre
leur voix à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle la france peut-elle
redevenir la première puissance
européenne dans le secteur agricole les
agriculteurs français peuvent-ils mieux
vivre de leur métier c'est le face à
face
et sur ce plateau philippe gurria si
vous êtes conseiller
régional europe ecologie les verts en
ile de france à face à vous il y avait
100 baladi conseiller municipal les
républicains à la mairie de paris
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être présent
sur ce plateau on vient de voir maxime
vaugeois au micro de guimard aussi un
éleveur qui a exposé ses difficultés il
ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs d'éleveurs
qui ont du mal alors qu'on la dit à la
politique agricole commune la réforme va
être votée finale demain avec les
eurodéputés reste rabou à strasbourg
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de lui
répondre à maxime bourgeois philippe
briat qui lui répondent la chose très
simple nous les écologistes nous ne
dénonçons pas les aviculteurs où les
paysans contraire nous les aimons et
d'ailleurs benoît biteau qui est un
paysan est sur la liste des européennes
de yannick jadot et le monsieur conseil
agriculture et paysannes de ninja d'eau
effectivement et la raison comment ils
font pour vivre aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs les paysans sont
prisonniers de la nef soeur ils sont
prisonniers de cette pac qui vous
obligent à augmenter la surface et donc
à être les esclaves de l'agroalimentaire
sion des multinationales nous nous
proposons de rediriger la pac est
différemment aujourd'hui 75% de ces deux
grands piliers de la pac il sur ces
fameux 10 milliards sont destinés
uniquement sur les grandes
concessions et donc forcément ces
agriculteurs sont obligés de s'endetter
il rentre dans une spirale infernale et
vous savez que 40 % des agriculteurs se
paie à peine 350 euros le mois vous avez
un suicide tous les deux jours et ça ça
ne te pull continuer on ne peut pas
congeler des poulets pour les envoyer en
au brésil et des forêts stella masoni
pour faire du soja pour nourrir
nos bovins il faut de la viande de bonne
qualité qui vit dans des conditions et
qui grandit qu'ils soient élevés dans
des conditions dignes et par entassées
comme ces fameux ferme élevage et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut réorienter la pac
vers tous ceux et toutes celles qui font
un effort considérable pour répondre aux
normes sanitaires qui répondront aux
normes écologiques soient pas soumis
arrêter la quantité et privilégier la
qualité complètement votre votre réponse
à maxime vaugeois qu'on avait également
micro de jim et rosie qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez vous vincent maladie j'ai
écouté l'agriculteur alors ce qui nous
est dit c'est que tout augmente est par
exemple il parlait de construction tout
augmente et la pac n'augmentent pas
alors certes même si on retranche le
royaume uni où on note une légère
augmentation donc sur les six années
mais par contre quand on regarde dans le
détail avec l'inflation c'est une baisse
de 10% de la pac donc concrètement de
nos agriculteurs vont continuer à mourir
de faim vont continuer à avoir des
problèmes il y aura encore des suicides
c'est malheureux je rappelle que la pac
aura 50 ans l'année prochaine que c'est
aussi un héritage des pères fondateurs
aussi de nous de notre famille politique
en tout cas de droite on est très
attaché à la pac bien évidemment il faut
plus d'écologie faut plus d'éco
responsabilité
mais consommé un légume qui vient je
rappelle qu'un légume sur deux vient de
l'étranger pour moi c'est pas du tout
écologique
justement les écologistes en tous les
cas les associations écologistes
demandent à ce que le texte aille plus
loin en matière d'environnement et de
climat
les français ce qu'ils sont prêts à
accepter le coup j'ai envie de dire le
coût en termes de prix alors qu'on parle
tout le temps dans cette campagne
présidentielle du pouvoir d'achat est ce
qu'ils ont les moyens de mettre plus
cher pour manger mieux pas vraiment
c'est sûr que si on le présente comme ça
je connais pas un citoyen qui vous avez
vous je veux payer plus et quand on
regarde ce qu'on a dans le portefeuille
on en a pas beaucoup donc c'est pas
possible de leur présenter comme ça faut
juste
réorienter
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure un
produit sur deux vient de l'étranger
alors que nous avons les capacités
aujourd'hui ici on en juge par des
patates mais en mangeant des chips
c'est vraiment des chips là c'est
vraiment le monde à l'envers non
simplement on peut produire ici on peut
produire local privilégier les circuits
courts donc là on enlève tout ce qui est
frais transparence a fait du bien pour
la planète parce que du coup il ya moins
d'effet de gaz à effet de serre mais
surtout surtout ça réduit les coûts et
puis comme je vous le disais nous les
écologistes demain nous ne voterons pas
le texte en l'état parce qu'il est juste
inadmissible il continue à précariser
les aviculteurs et continue à frapper
les consommateurs de manière solitaire
parce que lorsque vous voulez produire
en masse vous n'avez pas le choix
aujourd'hui il a fait ça est le plus
grand représentant des lobbys de 2,2 de
produits phyto dit sanitaires mais céder
voilà on est on est bien d'accord que
lorsque vous mettez du glyphosate
vous savez ce qui va venir derrière et
en plus les premiers qu'ils utilisent ce
sont les gags l'auteur etc des premiers
victimes de ces produits là donc c'est
pour une question de santé publique
nous devons sortir de ce modèle là et
donc par conséquent réorienter les aides
vers toutes celles et tous ceux qui
produisent de manière écologique et bio
en agriculture bio pas les fameux label
que nous avons fait le gouvernement et
monsieur de normandie ils ne veulent
surtout rien changer c'est pour ça que
le problème de cette pâte de laisser les
gouvernements d'autres en gros la fnsea
décider à qui il attribue des
subventions met en péril l'agriculteur
et le paysan qu'on a vu juste avant elle
aimait réellement perella les met en
danger nos donc nous nous proposons de
rééquilibrer sa de mettre les moyens
vers celles et ceux qui veulent
produire de bonnes qualités produire
locaux regardez le le fabricant dell du
triangle de gonesse on voulait
construire europa city sur des terres
agricoles pour nourrir sur lesquels on
peut nourrir les franciliens enfin le
monde marche à l'envers nous n'aurait
juste le remettre à l'endroit et on va
aller avec benoît biteau avec delgado
expliqué tout ceci est tout cela aux
agriculteurs et aux paysans et leur dire
que nous ne soit pas leur ennemi nous
sommes leur meilleure alliée mois sans
maladie moi je voulais juste d'agir sur
ça parce que moi quand je vois les
mairies
vers gauche dont dont des membres
écologistes parce que je vois c'est
qu'en ile de france il ya de plus en
plus de bétonisation
et malheureusement on sucre c'est si
j'ose dire un petit à petit des
exploitations agricoles donc faites ce
que je dis faites pas ce que je fais moi
je suis totalement pour effectivement
les exploitations agricoles je rappelle
aussi que la stratégie en france depuis
plus de 50 ans c'était la stratégie
aussi dans un contexte mondial se dire
que général de gaulle et et tout ce qui
a été fait derrière c'était de passer
d'augmenter un les structures
parcellaire et
d'augmenter la force agricole française
avec des structures plus grandes de
rentrer dans le xxème siècle puis dans
le 21e siècle la question aujourd'hui
c'est quelle est la stratégie de la
france surtout que cette pac elle va
donner plus de poids à la france aussi
dans la stratégie et c'est ça un peu qui
lui fait peur aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement français puisque le
gouvernement français malheureusement
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec le
gouvernement des bagnoles macro il il
réagit et il agit pas du tout c'est jari
réagit à tout ce qui se passe on est
dans un contexte mondial la france et
est troisième ex pote exportateur
mondial elle est passée sixième voire 7e
en agriculture il réagit mais n'agit pas
mais vous feriez quoi comment vous
feriez pour agir mais nous on ferait on
ferait concrètement cod où on
augmenterait notamment l'aide sur la pac
où on ferait de la transition en douceur
quand on voit par exemple qu'on nous
parle des pêcheurs on le dit oui il faut
supprimer il faut le matériel des
pêcheurs parce que s'ils ont pu les
licences c'est pas normal c'est anti
écologique par exemple donc nous on
agirait concrètement on a des députés à
l'assemblée nationale comme julien dive
qui ont des vues qui ont fait des
propositions concrètes vous ne pouvez
aller voir sur le site des républicains
sur l'agriculture on est le parti quand
même crédible aussi sur tous ces sujets
tout en mêlant l'écologie
il ya aussi la hausse du gasoil on l'a
entendu cet agriculteur maxime vaugeois
c'est 10 à 15000 euros de surcoût par an
ce que l'état survient
suffisamment pour pouvoir protéger ses
agriculteurs on voit bien une démission
totale du gouvernement macron et et
monsieur je viens de normandie qui qui
vraiment je suis pas sûr que tous les
agriculteurs et les paysans tu
connaisses élevé et les pêcheurs les
éleveurs connaît ce qui est leur
ministre de tutelle là on parle vous
parlez du gouvernement actuel mais quand
je cette question c'était plus sur
l'ensemble quand je disais à l'état la
politique agricole commune existe depuis
depuis bien longtemps il ya eu des
politiques de gauche et de droite
dans l'ensemble est ce que l'état survie
à vous l'a dit il y avait de gauche et
de droite mais il n'y a jamais eu
aujourd'hui des coûts de la politique
écologiste et c'est pour ça qu'il
faisait des années que je ne conduisais
pas jusqu'à maintenant
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons une
politique réellement réaliste est qui et
qui englobent la totalité vous savez
lorsque vous êtes un éleveur ou vous
êtes paysans où vous êtes un citoyen
lorsque vous allez à la pompe et que
vous payez de la tva sur des taxes là on
se dit en marche à l'envers alors c'est
sûr qu'il faut non simplement et des
aviculteurs faut leur permettre de
pouvoir passer sur des mécanismes
différents et beaucoup enfin et moins
énergivores sauf qu'aujourd'hui il y à
des lobbys qui imposent leur diktat et
vous voyez très bien que ce gouvernement
est aux mains des lobbys et le pays au
doigt et à l'oeil le bouton sur la
couture de celles et ceux qui ont qui
peuvent les aider à tout point de vue
moi sa maladie oui moi je fais moi je
pense
légalisme concrètement nous imposent de
plus en plus de bio dans les cantines
mais c'est pas du bio forcément français
c'est ça qui est des soins sur moi par
exemple je siège est à une commission
dans notre mairie d'arrondissement dans
le viiie concrètement on nous dit qu'on
peut pas favoriser les entreprises
parisiennes franciliens loup française
c'est pas normal du tout on est dans un
contexte mondial il ya une concurrence
internationale et celle à ouroux la
france et l'europe ne veut pas faire
tout le temps de d'angélisme abc on ne
peut pas faire d'angélisme mais simple
en forêt savoir si nos gouvernants
ont le courage d'imposer les normes
parce que c'est vrai que lorsque les
normes sanitaires les normes européennes
où les normes mondiales met en
concurrence les uns et les autres et
surtout parce que nous français on est
les bons élèves là-dessus lorsqu'on se
met tout de suite immédiatement donc ça
entraîne des surcoûts pour nos éleveurs
alors qu'en face avec je pense de ses
parents tafta cet art au mercosur nous
jouons pas avec les mêmes règles donc on
joue sur un terrain de foot certains ont
le ballon et nous on a pas sauf qu'on a
à l'équipement d'art et free qui nous en
empêche ça veut dire que faire du
protectionnisme oui le le le le pack
vert européen
va dans ce sens là
vous pouvez pas demander aux éleveurs
français de respecter les normes
sanitaires pour le bien-être de toute la
population et puis en attendant recevoir
du boeuf élevé aux hormones aux ogm qui
vient du canada ou qui vient du brésil
ou qui viennent d'argentine enfin c'est
pas réaliste donc il nous faut des gens
à la tête du gouvernement comme l'ennemi
jadot des gens qui sont capables de
taper du poing sur table ça c'est
impossible soit mais contre c'est là où
l'europe a un vrai enjeu c'est là où
l'europe à 27 un vrai poids si on part
chacun dans notre sens et dans son sang
sera mon unique et la pac actuelle qui
qui va être votée j'espère qu'elle sera
pas voté mais il donne le plein pouvoir
au pays de galles et jean moi je vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé en hongrie
en république tchèque c'est juste
scandaleux et donc là on a un exemple il
faudra pas du tout reproduire cet
exemple sur les vingt sept vous dites
justement qu'à 27 il faut se mettre
d'accord les italiens les syndicats de
travailleurs italiens eux veulent signer
des deux mains cette cette pac
oui parce qu'il ya tout un volet social
effectuons dans cette pac veut dire
qu'on n'est pas mauvais dans cette vague
après il faut être très réaliste ni à 27
c'est quand même compliqué ah bah oui
enfin je dirais maintenant à 26 je crois
avec le royaume uni en moi enfin enfin
moi ce que je pense vraiment c'est que
il faut vraiment qu'on se mettre tous
autour d'une table écologistes droite
centriste et c est qu on trouve une
solution au niveau européen cède pas
qu'effectivement je je je vois que ça
quand même fait avancer le bien-être
animal l'écologie c'est un point fort
alors je sais pas si mon si mon collègue
est d'accord mais en tout cas enfin moi
ce que je vois c'est que c'est quand
même bien maintenant il faut qu'on aille
plus loin et qu'on réfléchisse encore
une fois une stratégie sur le long terme
et malheureusement comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs en place à l'est sur sept ans
ce n'est pas le long terme
6h02 militaire 2027 effectivement c'est
pour ça qu'il faut agir maintenant parce
que là ça nous engage pendant six ans et
on peut pas faire machine arrière on
peut pas se permettre de perdre six ans
supplémentaires c'est pas possible et y
compris pour les paysans et les éleveurs
moi je le répète yannick jadot les
écologistes nous ne sommes pas les
ennemis des adultes nous sommes
effectivement les ennemis du racing
quand même pas forcément de vous mais on
parle beaucoup d'agrégats chine dont on
parle beaucoup de verges sur des choses
comme ça et on en parle ne le fait pas
lorsque nous nous le ferons on dit ce
qu'on fait on fait ce qu'on dit les
choses sont bien claires le virage il
faut le prendre maintenant on ne peut
pas se permettre de perdre encore cinq
années de plus et je redis et c'est
vraiment
c'est pas malheureux j'ai entendu le mot
ma note alors c'est pas malheureux mais
c'est un drame tous les deux jours un
paysan un éleveur un agriculteur tente
ou mais face à vie 40 % des agriculteurs
des éleveurs des paysans gagnent moins
de 350 euros par mois alors qu'il
travaille 70 heures par semaine c'est
pas possible on doit aller les aider on
doit aller le restaurant doit entendre
leur cri de détresse c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir et nous c'est ce que
nous proposons le mot de la fin pour
vous face aux maladies ben moi je dis
malgré un pack alors si on supprime la
pac je pense qu'ils seront encore dans
une situation bien plus compliquée donc
moi je suis pour cette pac pour
maintenant
agitation de la pâte la pâte dans l'état
actuel qui laisse c'est pas compliqué ça
approche peut profiter à des systèmes
mafieux hongrie en république tchèque
donc si vous laisser les états décider
juste est justement de la france et
qu'il faut aussi se comparer par rapport
aux autres pays européens il faut pas
oublier que l'allemagne ou les pays bas
produisent énormément en servent
aujourd'hui c'est plus forcément en
pleine terre comme en france il faut se
réinventer mais que ce soit écologique
et sur ce point je pense que nous sommes
d'accord merci vincent maladie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller municipal et l'air
à paris merci également philippe boyer
achi d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous êtes conseiller municipal europe
écologie vie général en france il ne me
suis pas 100 régionales nationales en
ile de france europe écologie les verts